[Musik]
hallo herr zusammenlief welt heute gibt
es ein leckeres mittagsgericht und zwar
werde ich gefülltem autos machen auf
türkische art denn darin ist eine
leckere kartoffelschälen das ganze ist
er getan hat und ich finden will braucht
auch absolut klasse leistung bringt auch
wenn du murat ince wird kommt man gerne
obst auch richtig für 250 gramm zu
machen brauche man gar nicht diese frau
wirklich super genial
ich habe vor kurzem auf der
livingkitchen so bereitet und das heißt
unseren jeden jedem sehr gut geschmeckt
du schreist du immer gerne einen joghurt
und das ganze ist popper ein kampf von
meiner freundin 100 von verletzt falls
dort wird ich weiß doch noch ihre egal
hauptsache es schmeckt es komme darauf
an vertrauen sonne und es kommt drauf an
wie schmeckt und ich sei du bist einfach
mal trifft den jusos habe ich selber
gemacht und sich da auch noch kosten für
den notar auch ich 200 ml 250 vier eier
und vier esslöffel olivenöl
den nudelteig könnt ihr jetzt mit den
händen oder auch mit der küchenmaschine
zu bereiten
das macht es in der küchenmaschine was
mich dann einfacher geht die zutaten
mehl und grieß jetzt noch die eier und
ich bin jetzt schon mal zu kneten und
gibt da noch das olivenöl meter hoch und
so entsteht ist gleich ein schöner
verzeigt
und derzeit werde so lange gibt es ist
ein schöner geschmeidiger models 13 14
verwundet aber noch ein bisschen feucht
ist die eier waren einfach ein bisschen
größer als gedacht mit gehe ich da noch
ein bisschen mehl dazu verteilt nämlich
nicht zu reichen
[Musik]
jetzt ist es fertig und es müssen
schnell noch besser teigs und bevor ich
ihn jetzt weitere wende muss ich ihnen
das erst einmal ein bisschen hohen
lassen dann kann sie nämlich viel besser
verarbeiten später als drücken sie nur
ein bisschen fleisch und speck ihn jetzt
ab und kann ihn der zwischenzeit schon
mal meine kartoffeln und abkochen
dann nämlich ist etwa 600 gramm und
lasst sie dann auch schon erfüllen und
ein jetzt weiter derzeit steht jetzt
noch kühl die kartoffeln habe ich jetzt
bereits ab ob du noch abkühlen lassen
und auch bereits geschehen ich zeige
euch jetzt mal die restlichen zutaten
für die füllung für die füllung frau
riss vier esslöffel olivenöl eine große
zwiebel oder 2 keine chance
ich habe 400 gramm und geschälte und ab
gekochte kartoffeln jeweils einen
teelöffel getrocknete münster und chilis
ich habe ich 13 etwas ratlos und pfeffer
und 1 bund petersilie
ich nehme mich zuerst einmal das
olivenöl kommt in die pfanne und werde
jetzt schon mal erhält und in der
zwischenzeit ex liebe in fein würfeln
[Musik]
zwiebelwürfel kommen jetzt in preise
verwendete mittel hilfe angebraten und
inzwischen kann ich schon mal die
abgekühlten kartoffel nehmen und tief
beim reiben und gefahr dass vieles
kaputt
ja
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die kartoffel mit in die
pfanne und werden jetzt mit angebraten
kann ich auch die hitze sondern wieder
hochschnellen
an der stelle gebe ich jetzt auch die
gewürze mit astor also ein bisschen
frisch geriebener muskatnuss frisch
geriebenen pfeffer dann auch falls 4 und
minze und beim salz müsse einfach selber
abschmecken wie intensiv wird mit ihm
haben möchte
und falls jemals zu viel salz mit dem
haft vor sich her immer eine kartoffel
in reserve haben den fall dass die
kartoffel einfach um diese weise wieder
ein bisschen auszugleichen
mit anbraten und der richtigstellung
gleich fertig
[Musik]
jetzt abdeckungen die kartoffel taschen
zu bereiten und zwar theilig netz und
zeigt ein bisschen glaub ich hab schon
vor mit den pink lacht und werdet mir
der nudelmaschine arbeiten falls ihr
keine nudelmaschine habt könnt ihr auf
einen aufbaustab nehmen zu viel
anstrengender und bei nudelteig ist es
so den gibt man jetzt durch die
nudelmaschine zuerst was ich die letzte
einstellung also diese einstellung und
dann fand ich ihn immer wieder dann wär
doch schön geschmeidig und auch für uns
lag am anfang ganz einfach sein also
noch ein bischen reis und so wird es
auch schön zusammengedrückt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
und immer mal wieder zusammen damit auch
der abschlussfilm gerade jetzt und ich
ein schönes weiterhin bekommen
[Musik]
vorbei die zeiten schöne versuche jetzt
ändern um den teig sinne ausfallen
[Musik]
deshalb ist auf stufe sechs ausgerollt
jetzt lege ich die platte vor mich hin
und die arbeit immer in schritten heißt
macht es erstmal den hier fertig und
dann die nächste portion die habe ich
wieder ein gefragt damit sie nicht
austrocknet hier bei der hälfte etwa
mach ich jetzt will schmidt und die
breite bis jetzt etwa 35 cm
ich rechne mit stolz und macht die
teigtaschen 6 auf 6 zentimeter groß das
heißt ich will jetzt aber tims stück
dahin müsste nicht so genau machen wird
auch ein bisschen ungenau und dann nehme
ich einfach einen teelöffel und da kommt
jetzt ein
[Musik]
jetzt bestreiten sie teilen damit etwas
wasser
das leben geht heute besser übereinander
und anderen noch
[Musik]
da die zweite klasse drauf und ich ziehe
jetzt so dass wir eben perfekt drauf
passt und drückt jetzt hier an den
rändern leicht selbst am besten mit dem
mieter anzufangen so kann nämlich die
luft noch mal nach außen gleiten
entweichen und dann die ränder und stand
ganz auf
[Musik]
und für mich einen ravioli schneider der
schweiz nämlich die teige durch und
prägt sie aber auch draußen
zusammengedrückt werden weil sie den ich
habe ihm die anzahl normalen peter
schneider oder ein messer und drückt man
die ränder mit babels und axel zugang
[Musik]
jetzt angerichtet werden ich habe schon
mal salzwasser und da gebe ich jetzt die
kartoffel passen rein also den bau trotz
eingetrübter mountain ski team
ausgeschlossen
und hier neben dran habe ich mir zwei
angebliche brot allein
denn sie werden später im sommer
geschwenkt mittel hoher hitze und dann
kommt noch ein bisschen paprikapulver
edelsüß hat peter pulfer also äpfel sie
könnte auch schaffen normalerweise über
die chance nehmen aber moral
empfindlicher was schärfe betrifft ich
mag's ich war es somit einmal brennt
jetzt und hier habe ich noch ein
bisschen joghurt und zwar einen
zehnprozentigen geburt mit salz und
pfeffer abgeschmeckt wer möchte kann
hier noch ein bisschen knoblauch
eingeben aber ich habe das nicht erspart
uns heute wobei ich mir persönlich viel
besser schmeckt mit knoblauch aber man
hat schimpft immer wenn ich verfüge noch
machen oder kein fleisch kein gemüse
[Musik]
sobald wir oben stehen sind wir dann
fertig damit verhalfen die botanische
für ausgemacht also merkt euch sobald
oben schwimmt es ist fertig oder an bord
oder oder so genau
beim fisch zum beispiel das ist auch
gebacken
er weist ein katholischer sagen wird
nicht dass leute das denke ich immer oh
ich bin mir vorgekommen eingeführt
dadurch geben wir natürlich auch nicht
aneinander und diese so sieht er auch zu
machen dafür sprechen sich jetzt sind
sie schon fertig sie passt er auf den
teller zwei dann 110 joghurt
professional ab ob genau und das ist
jetzt ohne joghurt wäre es auch komplett
ohne milchprodukte dame aus der 2 ich
habe sie leider vergessen den rat
vorstellen die verträge und deswegen ist
die soße lag trotzdem wird
bringt ein probiert 90 grad kann ich
dann auch mit einem messer das zu haben
also türk dem motto stoppt also auf der
livingkitchen geht um gut geschmeckt
diesmal ohne klub ich hab gemerkt auch
messen knoblauch unparteiischen
kontraproduktiv weil dann keiner mal mit
jemandem reden möchte nur wenn die
freundin
falls jetzt auch hunger bekommen hat und
lust auf dieses leckere rezept dann
schaut auf meinem blog vorbei aufs
tennis - dot de das gibt noch mal alles
ganz genau für euch schneelast ist hier
schmecken die übrigen bietet macht da
haben wir nicht alle auf essen kann ich
auch eins wären das heißt dann habt ihr
auch immer wenn sie auf vorrat und ich
wünsche euch jetzt mal ganz viel spaß
und nachmachen und nächsten mal passiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]